غيرت الحرب في اوكرانيا الخارطه السياسيه
وعلاقات الدول ببعضها البعض لم تكتفي بذلك
بل القت بظلالها ايضا على سوق السلاح
واثرت على طرق الدعم العسكري فالدول
الاوروبيه اليوم باتت تسعى للحصول على
اسلحه امريكيه ارخص واقل تطورا بما في ذلك
صواريخ المحموله على الكتف والمدفعيه
والطائرات بدون طيار التي اثبتت اهميتها
في الجهود الحربيه لاوكرانيا حيث كشفت
العديد من التقارير الغربيه ان الطلب
الاوروبيه بات يركز على الاسلحه والذخائر
الاساسيه التي تشمل قذائف مدفعيه من عيار
155 ملم ودفاعات جويه ومعدات اتصالات
وصواريخ جافلين التفكير الاستراتيجي في
العواصم الاوروبيه حول كيفيه خوض الصراعات
المستقبليه كانت داعم الاساسيه للتركيز
الاسلحه كبيره الحجم والاقل تكلفه بالنظر
الى التجربه الاوكرانيه التي اثبتت ان
الاسلحه عاليه التقنيه وباهضه الثمن لا
تؤتي بثمارها في الميدان الامر الذي شجع
دول القاره الاوروبيه على اتخاذ خطوات
استباقيه تجسدت في الطلب المرتفع وبشكل
خاص على قضاء فيلم مدفعيه من عيار 155 ملم
فالحرب الاوكرانيه كشفت عن الاهميه
المستمره للمدفعيه في المساعده على التغلب
على مواقع العدو او احباط تقدم القوات
الروسيه وهو ما جعل الطلبه يرتفع عليها
بشكل خاص